ahora quiere encontrar la derivada de la
función fx igual a x al cuadrado más 1
en el punto x igualados la tabla de
abajo muestra el promedio de la razón de
cambio de la función
f sobre el intervalo desde el punto x
hasta 2 o de 2 al punto x para los
valores de x que se acercan cada vez más
a 2 esta tabla muestra el promedio de la
razón de cambio de la función
f sobre el intervalo correspondiente ya
sea de x a 2 o de 2a x para valores de x
que se acercan cada vez más a 2 esta
parte nos está dando una pista de que
vamos a tener un límite por ahí de que
vamos a aproximar un límite o vamos a
calcularlo así es que veamos estos datos
que tenemos por acá por aquí tenemos
algunos valores de x
por acá el promedio de la razón de
cambio de estos intervalos que son
intervalos entre el valor de x y 2 así
es que ya tenemos el promedio de la
razón de cambio que ya cálculos hará no
necesitamos volver a calcularlo pero es
un muy buen repaso recordemos cómo le
haríamos para calcular este promedio de
la razón de cambio por aquí nos lo están
recordando y aquí x es igual a 1.9
entonces tenemos
efe de 1.9 cuál es el valor de f cuando
x es igual a 1.9 y después a eso
sara le restó el valor de f
cuando x es igual a 2 y cuanto sfn x
igualados pero bueno toda esta resta
junta
efe de 1.9 menos f de 2 es igual al
cambio en f pero lo tenemos que dividir
entre x menos 2
x es 1.9 1.9 y luego menos 2 así es que
aquí tenemos el cambio en f entre el
cambio en x esto de acá es el promedio
de la razón de cambio de f en este
intervalo y bueno ella escogió el
intervalo entre 1.9 y 2 y lo que obtuvo
es 3.9 pero luego se la tomó una x más
cerca de 2 ahora lo está haciendo entre
1.99 y 2 y obtuvo como promedio de la
razón de cambio 3.99 y esto parece como
que se está acercando cada vez más a 4 y
luego escoge una x todavía más cerca de
2 y obtiene un promedio todavía más
cerca de 4 y luego se pasa y se va del
otro lado ok por aquí podríamos decir
que está aproximándose a 2 del lado
izquierdo pero si ahora nos vamos del
otro lado por aquí x
se está aproximando a dos del lado
derecho y cuando x es igual a 2.1 el
promedio de la razón de cambio es 4.1 y
luego si x es igual a 2.01 otra vez nos
estamos acercando a 2 el promedio es 4.0
1 y eso también es acercarse a 4 entre
más nos acercamos al 2 el promedio se
acerca cada vez más a 4 y entonces lo
que estos datos nos están ayudando a
aproximar es esto
sabemos que el promedio de la razón de
cambio es f x - efe de 2 entre x menos 2
pero en lo que realmente estamos
pensando es cuál es el límite cuando x
tiende a 2 eso es en lo que nos están
ayudando estos datos y parece como que
este límite es igual a 4 eso es lo que
nos están diciendo estos datos que no
importa si nos acercamos del lado
izquierdo o nos acercamos del lado
derecho a 2
entre más nos acercamos a 2 esta
expresión que es el promedio de la razón
de cambio más se acerca a 4 y además tal
vez reconozcas en estos momentos que
esta expresión es la definición de
derivada bueno una de las definiciones
de derivada ok este límite es f prima
evaluada en 2 la derivada de la función
f en 2 es el límite conforme x se
aproxima a 2 de toda esta expresión hay
otras formas de expresar la derivada de
una función pero ésta también es una de
ellas así es que ya estamos listos para
contestar esta pregunta utilizando la
tabla a que se parece la derivada de la
función fx igual a x cuadrada más 1 en x
igualados bueno pues parece ser que la
derivada de la función en x igualados se
parece a 4 y listo ya terminamos